[Music]
winter soldier here we go back in the
fold mm-hmm how cool is it especially on
a scale of this size well it's really
nice to be here for sure especially on
this spacecraft probably the only time
I'll be on this base graph to be honest
yes the guardians of galaxy yeah it's a
question that I ask myself every tag I'm
gonna set yeah I don't know here we are
it's it's very strange for sure but but
a lot of familiar faces and that's
really always nice you know we kind of
get to come back together and there was
there was a lot of us on the last one on
the uncivil war so it doesn't feel so
strange but it's it's it's new for me
because there's a few people I have
never met you know they're like 64
Marvel characters a lot of people a lot
of people everybody's met everybody
right so has a lot of people coming
together on that that size and scope I
wonder if there's any parallels yeah you
stay in your lane you try not to bump in
anybody I'm sure there's a lot of
parallels between you know real life and
then kind of the relationships that are
in the movie you know people get to know
each other for the first time and scope
each other out I guess I don't really
know what I'm talking about because I
have not read a script I've never met
even half of the people in this cast yet
I've only I've done the majority of my
screen time with my friend Anthony
Mackie he couldn't be here because he
had to have one of those Cuban cigars
for all the effort that he's making on
wires
yes it's congratulating himself yeah
exactly
okay so are you serious you have a red
script no I have not No okay so what's
happening then
I don't know well fortunately there's
there's a you know there's a lot of kind
people that point point to where to look
and who to follow I guess but that's
okay cuz the Winter Soldier is always
kind of figuring out you know what where
he's you know what environment he's in
so bad guy what do we know about the
Winter Soldier right now well he's good
turned I think I think that's always the
question
you know and in a good way to be honest
because the thing is that I actually
haven't really thought about it other
than the fact that like every time you
see him he's in a very different place
and he's not really like a very I like
dangerous guy for the most part but I
feel like you know you still got the
hair and and and as long as he has this
situation going then I think he can look
a little skeptical got an edge yeah okay
talk to me about the relationship and
the chemistry really between the Winter
Soldier and the Falcon was it kind of
instant was it scripted was it to me
it's like Martin breasts film classic
Midnight Run you know it's really is
just sort of like in my head like 48
hours or or a buddy comedy from the
eighties you know or the nineties that's
that's how I see it you know we gotta
spit off Falcon we absolutely can yeah
absolutely
okay you know I mean the right people to
make that happen are certainly within
feet from us right now that's true
that's true what about the relationship
with Captain America Steve Rogers and
Winter Soldier where does that all stand
right now I think that's in a good spot
I think that's a good spot obviously
you're ovulating no okay it's it's tough
you know because it's interesting
actually because in life in the similar
way friendships develop and they change
and
sometimes you can know someone for you
know 15 20 years but people change and
sometimes they go in different paths and
those two guys have certainly known each
other for a long time and they have a
lot still in common and and and a bond
but now they've each had a lot of
separate life experiences so while they
do remain close it's interesting to
think about that they've actually become
different people than how they started
out so how that affects their
relationship is always going to be you
know this is this is as good as it gets
this is we are the last hope for
Humanity you want to get deep the world
is ending the world is ending in this
film and you know a couple of people
I've gotten together and they're trying
to to save it surprise but you know
that's that's the story so well talking
about massive in the scope and the
number of Marvel characters the
directors Joe and Anthony they posted a
shot did you see at the aerial shot of
trailer village yeah I was they're going
to you know get some eggs right people
were speculating like half of the
trailers were Robert Downey jr. 'he's oh
he's not here yet I don't think y'all we
would have known if he was here of some
sort and someone said that the trailer
with the solar panels had to be Mark
Ruffalo's well really why is that he's
really green environmentally friendly oh
that's right no I did hear that I didn't
know that yeah yeah I would explain the
silver little car that he's in I should
do that I should go green
so what's your your training regimen
like to get physically ready to be the
winter so well today I had a chicken
pesto pizza okay which was really good
yeah yeah exactly
I don't know I you know you you just
you just try and stay in shape simply
for the mere fact that you know we're
there's a lot of downtime and then
immediately your call to set immediately
you jump into that action sequence and
it's really hot out and so you just go
from zero to ten within you know five
ten minutes so just kind of keeping that
endurance up as is all I'm trying to
focus on and there is a gym on set I
haven't used it there's a gym my trailer
I think down he probably has that um but
but there is one near my place so I go
there you know 4:30 5:00 a.m. before you
come to set yeah and then you just are
ready whatever they say and then I'm you
know as ready as I can be
yeah who hits it hardest year you mean
like in a bar I think everyone's got
their own thing I mean Chris Hemsworth
certainly looks like you know he's
lifting Empire State building's I have
no idea I would say he's gotta figure it
out you know whatever he's telling thank
you thank you very much
you